welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity the mainstream media likes to
pretend there is no evidence Joe Biden
did anything wrong when it comes to
Hunter's business deals but now legal
experts are warning that Biden could be
in serious trouble law professor
Jonathan Turley says that if Joe knew
his family was engaged in influence
pedaling then he is corrupt by
definition and our own Greg Jared thinks
Biden's misdeeds could even Force Joe
out of the presidential race of course
more evidence will come to as the house
impeachment investigation continues and
here now with the latest on that effort
is house oversight committee chairman
James comr uh Merry Christmas thanks for
joining us I want you to know you are my
second favorite house committee
oversight committee chairman there's
ever been just so you I get that off my
chest the second best one ever I I wish
you worked for the Washington Post or
something that'll never happen but thank
you um listen uh one of the the things
that I just laugh about every time I see
hear the mainstream media there's no
evidence that Joe Biden has done
anything wrong but the money that's been
flowing into the Biden family business
and all those around him without a
product other than Joe Biden uh is
absolutely stunning when people ask you
that question how do you respond to
them well I think most Americans realize
that something stinks here most
Americans realize that we've provided
Bank stat Ms as hard evidence statements
that show the Biden have received well
over $20 million from our enemies around
the world and they can't answer a simple
question what did you do to receive the
money they also know that Joe Biden
stated during the campaign he never met
with any of these people who sent his
family money and that he had a wall
between the government and his family
Shady business schemes we know now
because of our investigation that he
sent dozens and dozens of emails in a
pudm to many of these business
associates they won't turn those emails
over as you know Jason that's part of
the evidence we're we're continuing to
seek to receive through this impeachment
inquiry and we know that he communicated
with every single person that he said he
never met with that send his family
millions and millions of dollars around
the world so the American people know
something stinks here and uh that's
going to be a problem for Joe Biden
moving forward not only are his policies
a disaster but the American people think
he's a crook
tell me go through the list if you will
just off the top of your head of
documents and things that you're wanting
to see that you haven't yet been able to
get your hands
on well first right now I think one of
the most important uh amount of
documentation that we need are those
pseudonym emails remember no one knew
about these pseudonym emails until a few
months ago uh we found that Joe Biden
was using at least three fake names on
government emails uh what what we didn't
know until recently was that he was in
fact using those ponm emails to
communicate with not just his son Hunter
bide but also with his Shady business
associates uh the Politico in their ever
never-ending defense of Joe Biden uh
wrote a story when the White House
turned over
14 of these emails which didn't even
amount to half of 1% and said oh there's
nothing here these are junk emails but
what we learned from the indictment in
California several of those emails that
that uh Joe Biden used a ponm uh were
used as evidence against Hunter Biden in
his failure to pay taxes so there's that
is important evidence there we also need
those depositions there's certainly a
reason that uh Hunter Biden's not
wanting to come in and answer questions
we have his bank statements and and bank
records don't lie so we want to we want
to depose Hunter B obviously want to
depose all of the business associates
but we also need those those sum emails
and we also have questions for the
National Archives which countries were
involved in the documents that Joe Biden
mishandled that's something that I think
is very important of our investigation
because we've identified Jason a couple
of emails that hunter sent to people in
Ukraine for example that we believe may
be may have been classified documents
that uh that Joe Biden mishandled that
were in
uh possibly the garage of Joe Biden's
house where his son was
living and and finally uh Hunter Biden
not showing up before the committee with
the duly issued subpoena how soon do you
think the house would actually move to
hold him in
contempt I hope it's as soon as we get
back I mean I think most uh of my
colleagues will go home they'll spend
time with their family they'll go to
ball games they'll hopefully go to the
grocery store they'll hear from their
constituents and the constituents want
to know what's going on here they want
to know is our president for sale has
our president been conspiring with our
enemies around the world for millions of
dollars uh that was sent to his family
this isn't normal behavior and the media
can write no evidence no evidence all
day long that's not going to change the
fact that there's a lot of evidence
there are a lot of questions here that
this family has failed to answer the
media you know thinks that they can
attack me or Jim Jordan and it's going
to discredit this investigation but poll
after poll shows a majority of Americans
are keeping up with this and they expect
someone to investigate public corruption
they know the FBI has failed to do their
job they know the IRS has failed to do
their job and and they know that uh the
Department of Justice has failed to do
their job so the only entity that's left
out there is the house oversight
committee thank God the Republicans won
the majority and we have subpoena power
we're using that subpoena power in a
discipline and transparent manner to try
to get the truth to the American people
about whether or not this President is
compromised chairman comr thanks for
joining us on Hannity Merry Christmas
and happy New Year appreciate it hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else